welcome back to this special edition of
hannity
as you know sean sat down earlier this
week for an exclusive interview with
caitlyn jenner who is running to unseat
california governor gavin newsom
in a recall election here's a little bit
more of that interview that we haven't
shown you yet
where jenna reacts to sean's questions
about california's
sky high tax rate have a look
i had budget meetings the other day
since i'm coming in as i'm new to this
um i want to get as much information as
i can and there's certain things
a governor could do and certain things
the governor can't do i i can't say
we're going to lower taxes and taxes are
lowered it's just not going to happen it
is a process
but as governor the first thing i can do
is i can freeze everything stop
okay um i don't want people leaving this
state i feel like i'm on a big white
horse riding into the state you know and
saying hey
stay stay there's a little hope on the
horizon here okay
uh but we need to stop everything okay
we cannot
taxes okay we have the highest marginal
corp tax rate in the nation at 13.3
new york's about to beat you they're not
far behind yeah yeah
yeah and and that's good they're talking
about going to 18. oh god
um and we have the highest sales tax
7.25 percent we've got the
gas tax right now was a little over 50
cents a gallon
um we're taxed everywhere we go a lot of
people who think they're oh i don't pay
taxes i don't make
enough money you're paying taxes as soon
as you walk out that door
all day long you know anything you go to
the grocery store you buy a car
we're paying taxes all the time we take
first of all we on taxes
we stop everything hold it they have
stuff on the books right now that they
want to tax people for leaving
for the next 10 years 10 years yeah yeah
next 10 years
what are they going to do build a wall
around the state and have two
exits now all of a sudden the left will
support walls to keep them
yeah they were there to keep the state
you know keep everybody in
how do they charge you a state income
tax if you don't live in the state
i i don't know they would have to build
an enormous bureaucracy
in sacramento and around the country to
try to collect that money
it would they would waste more money
than they would actually wind up
collecting because nobody would pay it
uh they want to do things like that and
i'm looking at this thinking those are
coming
some of the stupidest ideas so let's
just
stop everything and take a close look at
what we're doing
you know regulations
sean we have
21.2
million words of regulations
if you read 300 words a minute worked a
40-hour work week
it would take you three years to read
all the regulations we have regulations
on the books
that were there before the fax machine
does the governor this is a great point
does the gov as governor would you have
the authority
i have the authority to freeze it no
more regulation
and get rid of the old ones i would
start that process
okay first thing i would do is do a
review board okay
that's just gonna through go through
every regulation
in the past they would put out a
regulation you know it really didn't
work very well what we need now is
another regulation up on top
you know of it they're overlapping over
totally overreaching but if you can get
a group to actually go through
every regulation it would be a tough job
get rid of the ones
that are just not you know
today the world is so different with
computers and how things work
every it's a different world today once
which ones are
actually good some regulations are good
i mean we need a few
okay um but we don't need
all these regulations and then anybody
comes in
once we lift this freeze
on them once anybody comes in and wants
to put another
regulation you have to get rid of
probably at least three regulations that
are already on the books
we're just not going to continue we're
the most regulated state in the nation
and it doesn't have to be that way you
need somebody
up there that is going to change this
right now after
almost 40 years of you know democrat
rule up there
gavin newsom they're not doing anything
about it and we have to do
we're regulated to death you know taxes
yeah yeah they want to tax us when we
leave and they want to tax us when we
die
so any way out of this state is probably
not a good idea hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else